visitors to the International Spy Museum
in Washington DC have a completely new
experience after a nearly three-year
upgrade the brand-new 140,000 square
foot space opened to the public over the
weekend museum is packed with nearly
10,000 artifacts and interactive
exhibits they include this pixelated
disguised mask that prevented real-life
spies from being identified by overhead
surveillance Carol Burnett is inside the
museum there all good morning good
morning I'm loving the background music
there surely you recognize this
gentleman to my left the country's first
president George Washington take a look
at what's in this enclosure though to my
right it's an actual letter he wrote in
1777 it's difficult to see but it
effectively establishes the country's
very first spy network to take on the
Brits this is where America's spy story
begins and this 162 million dollar
museum is reimagining what it means to
be a spy you'll be assigned a cover
identity
this wouldn't be a spy museum without a
covert alias assigned to every visitor
Nikko Damir from Puebla City Mexico
I'm a photographer lead curator Alexis
Albion showed me one exhibit pulling
back the veil on the lives of
international spies like the so called
Mata Hari
a Dutch spy an exotic dancer she didn't
spy for very long only really a few
months and of course she ended her life
really tragically she was executed
during World War one for espionage
you'll also find a high altitude flight
suit on loan from the CIA the idea was
to keep the pilot alive and these spy
planes so that they could capture
imagery from the skies and this ice pick
used to assassinate a Soviet exile
you can still see actually the rust mark
right on the blade there with the bloody
fingerprint of the
many if not most of the artifacts here
in the new museum originated in my
personal collection intelligence
historian H Keith Melton spent 45 years
tracking down what he calls history's
obscure artifacts
he now has 7,000 of them there is a
hidden world behind every newspaper
headline every television story on
international relations the true stories
are even more fantastic than the fiction
like that of the so-called Russian 10 a
group of Russian spies living as
suburban couples the inspiration for the
TV program the Americans my wife
Elizabeth page 3 for which Melton served
as a consultant in the FBI this is their
greatest counter intelligence success in
history computer images of flowers which
the Russians embedded with secret
messages are on display next to the
handcuffs used to arrest and a Chapman
and the nine others in 2010 good spying
Melton says prevents conflict more wars
are fought because of faulty information
and good information Colonel Chris Costa
is a former military intelligence
officer in the museum's executive
director he explained why American
intelligence failures like those which
preceded 9/11 and the Iraq wars are also
on display we don't always get it right
and learning comes from success as well
as failures the key question being what
why was there an analytical failure
that's why we spy one exhibit even comes
with a warning the room on enhanced
interrogation a practice now banned by
the US government we show the evolution
from current day backwards throughout
history the deed is all not the glory
that's a credo we live by Colonel Costa
also emphasized that spy craft is not
for everyone
it's a quiet profession our work is not
lauded we're happy working in the
shadows but in the case of the spy
museum we have a gift and that is the
gift to educate the public on what this
work is all about
and interestingly enough everything on
display here including this infinity
room is not in position to convince
people to want to join the world of
espionage and surveillance in fact the
lead curator I spoke with said if app
took up seeing everything in this museum
that the risks the failures people
actually realize they do not want to
become spies she said she would look at
that as a success because the world of
deception she says is not for everyone
Nora well I love that Harel thank you
that line the deed is all not the glory
that's the credo that the spies live by
another good place to visit in
Washington DC you go